40 miles off the coast of south
australia shark scientist dr charlie who
veneers and phd student madeleine reilly
investigate the best way to fend off a
shark attack
gonna pass it across
the answer may be to prevent it in the
first place
and then we just need a few baits ready
and you're good to go all right sounds
good let's hope the sharks stick around
fingers crossed
their theory that the shark's ampullae
of lorenzini can be used against it
they're testing a new shark deterrent
that does just that
the sharks are capable of detecting
minute electric field and the idea of
these electric deterrents is to transmit
a very strong electric field that will
overwhelm that sense of the shard so
that as the sharks get too close it's
like kind of nearly receiving a punch in
the face and the shark just basically is
deterred
there's a lot riding on this test
most shark deterrents are designed to
protect just one person
this one which has been tested for two
years
is much more ambitious
[Music]
if all goes well it'll be powerful
enough to keep sharks out of a section
of the ocean 25 feet in diameter by 50
feet deep
without harming any swimmers
that's bigger than most swimming pools
how it works is this big white thing is
a float it just floats it on top of the
water
this black module is where the power
comes from and then underneath we've got
a four meter long electrode which
actually emits the electric field which
theoretically deters a shark
got it
yep got it
[Music]
the first thing they'll need to test the
deterrent
sharks
within moments a 13-foot great white
turns up
all right we've got a shark coming in at
the back
and seems curious about the device
a large piece of bait hangs near the
electrode
if the shark's hungry it'll have to
fight through the electric field to get
to it
the team will film the shark's reaction
then analyze it after
the shark circles
clearly intrigued by the tasty morsel
floating in the ocean
coming back around
scientists monitor the action as best
they can from the deck
they know that the entire test is riding
on this moment
investigators wait to see if the great
white will break through the constant
electric current
the shark gets closer and closer with
each pass
[Music]
but doesn't bite
the team reviews the footage looking for
the telltale muscle spasm
that signals that the electrical current
affected the shark when it reacts
oh did you see that oh you can actually
literally see the pectoral fin
flicking down yeah
it's a subtle movement but the slight
flick of the shark's pectoral fin tells
the research team the deterrent seems to
work
that first like flexing of the pectoral
fin that's a standard reaction to an
electric field that we've seen in the
past yeah
we're in the really early stages of this
testing but if we get more really good
trials like we've had today then we'll
get a clearer understanding of how
effective this deterrent actually is
[Music]
you